a small island in the Black Sea has
become a key Battleground in the Russia
Ukraine war Russia seized it at the
start of its Invasion snake island is
just over half a kilometer long and 200
kilometers south of the Ukrainian Port
of Odessa it's seen as vital to Moscow
and it's bid to control the Western
Black Sea no wonder then you know
Ukraine wants it back and continues to
launch attacks on Russian military
equipment there including ships
it may look like just a tiny lump of
rock in the middle of the Black Sea but
snake island has enormous strategic
importance for both Russia and Ukraine
so significant that it's become a key
Battleground in this war
Ukraine has even produced a stamp in its
honor
on it an illustration of a Ukrainian
Border guard standing on the island and
making a rude gesture it was inspired by
Roman reboth who received a medal for
refusing to surrender The Isle to the
crew of a Russian warship at the start
of the war
his curse words to the Russians have now
become a popular Ukrainian slogan
Russia though did take Snake Island an
outpost that used to be under Soviet
control
if the Kremlin could occupy it
permanently it would control even more
of the Black Sea
that would help it continue to block the
export of Ukrainian Goods such as grain
from Key port cities like Odessa
Ukraine has been doing all it can to
take Snake Island back
successfully targeting Russian military
equipment on the island and Beyond
the mosqueover seen here in its prime
was Russia's Black Sea flagship
but it was destroyed by Ukrainian forces
in April
Moscow is fighting back
British intelligence believes Russia is
trying to reinforce its Garrison on
Snake Island
including setting up long-range air
defense systems
military experts warned that could be a
threat not only to Ukraine but also to
its neighbors and NATO
and so the battle for this strategic
Outpost goes on
with neither side prepared to back down
we can take a closer look with Dimitri
alperevic who's a security expert at the
Silverado policy accelerator that's a
geopolitical think tank in Washington DC
welcome to DW and what's your assessment
then how important is it to control this
tiny Island
well symbolically of course it's very
important given the episode that was
just described early in the war and the
Valiant resistance from the ukrainians
and defending it but here's the issue
that the Russians face now this island
is essentially indefensible now given
that the warships um that they that
would provide the air defense
capabilities for the island like Moscow
can be sunk by the ukrainians with their
Neptunes as they capably demonstrated
last month so they have a real issue now
facing targeting from tb2 drones from
Turkey of personnel on that island
equipment on that island just a few
weeks ago the ukrainians destroyed an
air defense system on it so now uh it's
really questionable why they want to
keep it so badly given that they're
going to continue suffering severe
casualties on it okay so Russia having
problems defending it but Russia says
Ukraine's taking heavy losses as it
tries to recapture it and what do you
think is Ukraine right to keep focusing
on on this uh this uh this little
Outpost
again symbolically it's very important
but for the ukrainians also this is not
a strategic Island and one that they can
probably defend even if they're
reoccupied because the Russians can of
course conduct their strikes against it
and take out any personality and air
defense systems that are on this island
and here's the problem it really won't
stop the blockade the blockade is
largely being enforced with submarines
with surface ships with our airstrikes
and artillery and and missiles on in
Crimea and Oni snake island is really
not going to change the picture much for
the ukrainians right so you seem to be
saying that that albeit it's
symbolically important it really doesn't
make that much difference
that's right and primarily because of
its size it's less than 0.2 kilometers
in size uh and uh it's just too small to
put significant forces on it to put
radar and significant air defenses that
can be taken out with uavs like the
ukrainians have done in the past because
I've looked at reports the same reports
of people thinking well okay but it does
have a significant potential to wreak
havoc on other European countries
it's it's pretty far and look the
Russians don't need Snake Island to
wreak havoc on the European countries if
they want to do so they control pretty
much the Black Sea with the Black Sea
Fleet even with the loss of the masquale
they still have a number of frigates
that are highly capable of long-range
missiles on those frigates they have
submarines they have a porcelon distance
Aviation that's located in Crimea so
Snake Island really doesn't change the
picture much for them that's very
interesting thank you so much for uh
sharing your expertise with us Dimitri
alpenovich Security Experts at the
Silverado policy accelerator
thank you